[Music]
real quick i just wanted to show you
something that i thought you probably
enjoy
every single brendan schaub roll that
he's ever had on tv from 2009 to 2022
the entire video is only five minutes
long
oh my g really yeah i swear to god bro
you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
rogers is an athletic big guy i know
he's undefeated but i think i'm better
in every category when it comes to
fighting oh man look how much better he
talked
look at the difference in how he talked
right
like it is because of the punches i
don't buy the speech impediment thing
i mean he is
yeah his brain's not totally damaged yet
yeah is the way i pay my bills for
marcus i think it's more of as a hobby i
don't think he's used to training twice
a day and eating right and stuff like
that so i i think it's a rude awakening
for him and a couple other guys in the
house brendan's a big kid too but not
anywhere near as big as d'amico this is
definitely
dunking on i mean before he became
famous definitely a fight between two
big boys denver colorado we are going to
investigate this place and we'll be
joined by did he do a ghost adventure
no i didn't know this i didn't know the
travel it was travel hd travel hd yo we
need to do this at as like a bonus yeah
this will be a bonus trip it won't even
count against the main riff but i will
love you if you know we should just do
we should do this episode after a full
movie reflection yeah yeah just keep
doing a half hour yeah exactly
oh dude we really should we really
should if we could find this one because
it's only going to be probably 22
minutes when you take commercials out
special guest ufc fighter brendan chob
ladies and gentlemen i give you brendan
schubb
ufc fighting
already got it thank you
what happened to a girl down here
she was great
bro what the [ __ ] is this
oh my show katie and ida who blew up the
team got gary barnett fired she's she
liked it with a dick taste oh yeah
wait she was uh
hey it's brittany palmer and i'd love a
great day at the beach
wait this is all he did on this show
[Music]
thanks for watching remember so we're
doing a whole episode on video games yes
we are adam and jamie have just finished
they're going to shoot brandon shaw with
a gun adam and jamie are joined by a
complete [ __ ]
they're first-person shooter but an
accurate avatar they're not that's where
this guy comes in
[Music]
hold on a second
max ben bench press 390 come on man why
would you
total badass
what [ __ ] dumbass
oh in the face
got him
right in the money maker
yes sir
i mean you know what i forgot to use the
backpack this is brian kellen fighting
the kid my friend brandon chubb here
this young lady over here is an expert
in lie detector i'll go first uh is that
a real rolex
no
get back in here
he had a fake rolex on
that's
really funny what's wrong with you man
holy [ __ ] did he get into the bahamas
when he went on a cruise or something
yeah is it fogging up yeah vehicle this
is a secure government installation and
you can't walk around here without a pt
pen no pt belt no access what is this
from what is this from what is this from
what is this from hold on i miss where
it's from
this i want to see this we might need to
riff this range 15 what's range 15 i got
you
what is this oh my god all right you
know what cancel the [ __ ] ghost
hunters i think we got a full riff
what do we got with range 15 holy [ __ ]
oh it's a show i guess
let's see
range 15
was the show on imdb
on imdb no i'm so sure sorry it's a show
i'm looking at
it's on what
what what is this what is this show oh i
said it's in show links my bad no no
okay sorry sorry sorry um
which i'm just trying to see what
channel this show was on i don't even
know what it is
no
range 15 is a zombie comedy film so it
is a movie
it's on freebie it's like on one of
those shitty free like streaming
services like crackle oh my god the cast
you ready
okay um
it's matt best internet personality
um
nick
palm i don't know that is uh vincent
rocco vargas actor writer producer tim
kennedy retired mma fighter randy
couture retired actor and retired mma
fighter um leroy petrie uh clinton
romeshaw dale dye evan hater evan hater
okay say evan hayford this is the guy
black rifle company co-founder this
movie
was a [ __ ] one of those comedy movies
that black right
yes
yes it's 92 minutes we have to watch
this merch we have to
we have to watch this this is a black
rifle coffee movie this is this is like
several of our worlds coming together
that has brendan schaub
hold on check this out
danny trejo's in it
uh william shatner's in it
uh brendan schaub we know brian callan
we know
ron jeremy is in it
this is next month's riff right we have
to do this this goes to the top with the
ghost thing this one goes yeah cause
this this is the only 99 this will
probably be a little shorter yeah this
is a 90 minute movie so this will be
perfect we'll give you two oh god i
can't wait at least i can't wait
and you can't walk around here without a
pt belt no pt belt no access buddy whoa
whoa whoa now i don't have any pt belts
but what i do have is some challenge
coins huh
all right there we go oh
man there you go
just kind of
kind of put yourself back does it go
that way no it's a new gate
[Music]
this has to happen
this has to happen yes
[Music]
you guys have a moral clause here this
is your signature right i'm looking at
both your signatures right there yeah
yeah that's a mistake to sign [ __ ] you
don't read so this isn't about the coke
machine this is not about a coke machine
told you dumbass
is this
what is this it's [ __ ] brilliant is
what it is it's a comedy sketch of the
highest order it's it's [ __ ] black
rifle had more money and they know what
to do with and they threw money two guys
they recognized from the internet to
make a funny thing for them
all right so this is from a show called
last meal with brandon i don't know what
this is
[ __ ] last meal
do you watch food network i do you watch
food network while you're cutting weight
i feel like it's a bad idea like during
fight week i take out the guys and like
feed them all good you just stare at
them i eat like a whole salad so this is
easy for you i know right
all right guys our guest today is the
former ufc
brandon chop
was on ridiculousness
of course why would brandon schaub was
on wikitosh do you think that [ __ ]
brandon schaub has not crossed paths
with rob deer deck before first off look
man
i don't understand the ridiculous is
[ __ ] is is basically you don't think
they all those years of both of them
shopping at the douche store at the von
dutch at the von dutch store yeah they
ran into each other buying a no hat new
new trucker hats
key fighter a super podcaster and host
of show times below the belt welcome
brendan shaw former host of showtime
are you a fan of the selfie i believe
you're a pretty decent selfie shooter
i'm all right i mean
and i'm not great i'm all right i mean
chanel is better for sure how we doing
my man another shop for the road
no i probably shouldn't man i'm
shooting my first comedy special tonight
oh this is from his [ __ ] showtime
special
i dabbled a little myself in coming how
long you been doing it
three years three years huh
so why is the bartender mark harley why
is he playing mark harley as the
bartender
that's true why don't you just get more
garlic yeah this one's on me man jesus
christ this [ __ ] town
the tax collector
fergie what's the tax collector
when you kill a man oh he was just like
an extra like a hired goon
you won't kill his sons this is what
happens alex uh this is kim kim alex hey
before we get [ __ ] is film fest
get too loaded i may have some news hey
hey hey man hey man you from that tv
place you drove from the tv place in
your mercedes benz
wow he's a bad actor very bad at this
in l.a
oh oh
i'm sorry mr hollywood elite bro what a
bad actor
he's like
and this is the the take that they used
yeah [ __ ]
that's my bad no yeah i think you're
fine man if you were auditioning for the
role of local town bully in a movie that
i was casting i would ask you politely
to tone it down and i don't know if it's
the beer or just my words but let me
make it simple for you you
are underwritten ow
and that's all of brandon shop's uh film
and tv roles up until this point
well that's um
well that is a that's a career
he was def he definitely appeared on
some stuff
um
you